soccer in 40 degrees celsius heat
the players wear dortmund and bayern
munich shirts but this match is far
away from the bundesliga in kunduz
province in northern afghanistan
sophiola zahiwal has a dream to play in
afghanistan's premier league and one day
perhaps in spain or germany
he also dreams of peace
if there's conflict it's impossible to
play football
because people flee the country
playing soccer in afghanistan isn't
without risk
there's the constant threat of a
terrorist attack kunduz province remains
dangerous
even more now that german troops are
withdrawing
the taliban controls some areas
soccer is huge in afghanistan and so are
its superstars such as cristiano ronaldo
who's supposedly more popular than
president karzai
sofia watches the champions league with
his friends
real madrid are playing galatasaray
is his favorite player today he's
wearing a manchester city jersey
and socks and shorts from his favorite
spanish teams
the 24 year old is serious about his
soccer career
but he's worried about the future of
afghanistan
i've been playing since i was a boy i
love the game with
all my heart but if the taliban came
back
that would affect soccer too sofia
and his friends were among the hundreds
of thousands who filled the streets when
afghanistan won the south asian
championship in september
they beat india 2-0 a victory that
seemed to give the entire nation a much
needed boost
and this is the victory song a catchy
tune that celebrates the historic win
and pays tribute to the players who
brought the trophy home
soccer in afghanistan suffered under the
taliban
but the game has come on considerably in
recent times
the country now has its own premier
league
shafiq gauhari ran several german-funded
infrastructure development projects in
afghanistan before turning his hand to
soccer
soccer can help people come together and
become friends with one another
when that happens i think it can make an
important contribution
to peace
an important contribution perhaps but
soccer alone cannot deliver
lasting peace to afghanistan